Satie had this boyfriend and like one
day I don't I just ended up making out
with him it was really terrible of me
honestly when it comes to him I'm like
anything anyone tells me I'm not shocked
but it's the fact that I don't think I
told you everything and I feel like I
need to hello and welcome to split
decision I'm your host kot Takahashi and
today is the best friends episode these
women are true best friends they know
everything about each
other or do they okay ladies Split
Decision is about one thing finding deep
and meaningful truth first prompt is I'm
the more intelligent one in the
Friendship make your split decisions in
three 2
1 all right go ahead and turn
around okay Hannah Caitlin you both
think you're the more intelligent one
yeah we always say this I think Caitlyn
has more Street smarts I have more like
classroom book smarts I have a 4.0
though okay well High School oh yeah
High School yeah you're more Street
Smart I'd say but I'm more like
intellect Smart in my head yeah I think
do you agree with that yes and no she is
definitely book smart for sure she got
her Masters so she and I'm getting my
masters too but yeah I yeah I think so
yeah but I think I'm definitely more
Street Smart yeah yeah I would agree
yeah well who do we think has more
common sense me it depends it depends
maybe Caitlyn though in maybe I you
don't sound so sure I think of like
worst case scenarios so then I think
everything out and then Hannah's I think
like I said more I want like naive is
like I don't want to say negative word
but like you're super smart but then you
see the best in everything and I see
worse which is probably not healthy but
I think I have enough common sense to
like get by but Caitlyn's the type of
person like go into a restaurant like
she'll get like oh I get
I don't let people walk all over me yeah
Audrey you're the smart one huh yeah
tell us more I think I just make smarter
decisions uh overall than she does I
think I'm more like financially
responsible like they said I'm kind of
like more street smart and you agree
with this you're
yeah so I kind of grew up um you know I
don't want to say spoiled but like I
kind of had everything kind of handed to
me and grew up with an actor as a dad so
like I kind of didn't get to experience
like I don't know like a normal way of
growing up I guess and that's where she
comes in where it's like she just kind
of is like Maddie like you can't do this
like you have to make sure you're doing
this like just just on top of me as like
a big sister basically s Eve so we are
in agreement
yeah definitely in the book smart wa
like I went to college and graduated the
thing about EV is I think that she's
very very Street Smart like she's very
intelligent she doesn't use it most of
the she doesn't use her
intelligence call like she like knows
the right thing to do in a situation and
then she doesn't do that yeah I feel
like I'll go to S and I'll be like hey
girl really need some advice and then
you talk at me for like two hours and
I'm like totally totally and then dude
the opposite Rebecca Rosy you got the
tell us more um I think that you are
more street smart but I'm more book
smart but like barely because I feel
like we're like really like right there
with each other I would say her career
and stuff like that like she's always
just been like very intelligent always
wanted to move forward and I went
through a lot of stuff cuz I you know
just got a relationship so I'm like kind
of like little bit well kind way behind
I'm going to be honest I think it's good
to have both so I think that we Balan
each other out even with what you're
wearing you're like the yin and yang
coming literally balancing each other
out yeah definitely we've been friends
for seven years now we met through this
app actually called radiate and it's for
like ravers it's like you have your
party friends and then you have like
your friends that you could you know
talk deeply to but for us it was both oh
yeah definitely a Raves you haven't been
one go to one the next prompt is I think
my best friend is or has been jealous of
me make your split decisions in three 2
[Music]
one okay go ahead and turn around je
my Hannah and Caitlyn so we both say yes
yeah I don't think jealousy is the right
word because it's like malicious I think
but like I don't I love your body you
have nice boobs like I'm jealous of your
body when you eat you don't gain weight
I'm jealous I am jealous of that so far
from the truth it is true I feel like
your family situation too like I'm
jealous of that like I wish I had that
kind of where my parents still like paid
for a lot of stuff
not true somewhat true but mostly not
wait what's not true that my parents
like pay for everything everything like
you do work hard like you do get a lot
of stuff paid for still like do you pay
do you pay for your cars right now I
paid for my car like your insurance no I
do not pay for my insurance do you guys
pay for your I don't know like I wish I
wish I had who here pays for their car
insurance I pay for everything with my
car all right well that's a half that's
like
50/50 I wish I had that even though it
Tau me to hard and you work hard like
you do but I wish I had that too Eve
thoughts growing up when we were in high
school we talked about this like the
other day we were like totally idolizing
each other's bodies all the time like I
wish I had your body wish I looks like
you I know thank you but yeah I mean I
think at this point no it's like the
same thing everyone's saying we we
balance each other out so well like
there's so much Beauty I find in you and
then yeah I don't know I'm yeah but
there's just nothing to be jealous of
anymore it's like we just love each
other so much um we've been best friends
for over 10 years she went to Ireland
for a year and when she came back we
went to middle school together and
that's I feel like when we became in
like
Inseparable the next prompt is we have
hooked up with the same
person make your split decisions in
three two one
okay go ahead and turn
around all right okay Eve yeah tell us
about it okay we both had these
boyfriends and then we like
coincidentally hooked up with each
other's ex-boyfriends at different
periods yeah we kissed them Satie had
this boyfriend and like they were so off
and on and then like one day I don't I
just ended up making out with him it was
really terrible of me so shady honestly
I don't really blame her for that he was
like actually like a Serial cheater and
I was like an idiot and so I was like
it's fine cuz I think that you're cute
and so you can cheat on me and I'll take
you back and then oh you guys were
together it wasn't an ex-boyfriend it
was your boyfriend at the to well so she
thought we were broken up but we had
gotten back together that morning yeah
well how did that feel for you when you
found out well actually I found out like
a year later he was really manipulative
and he convinced her that if she told
she wanted to tell me like the next day
when she found out we got back together
she basically said like if you tell her
she's going to stay with me and she's
going to cut you off forever oh wow and
I totally believed him and was like
really yeah he was really threatening so
then I called Eve and she came over and
we talked about it that day and then I
think it took us that day to get over it
too yeah and then I took him back
again but well the next thing happened
after high school and this one was like
a little like yeah so Eve had a
boyfriend in high school yeah and for
years he was the best friend actually of
mine and it was like New Year's Eve she
wasn't like at this point they had been
broken up for a little while and she was
like engaged but like let's not engag
okay and we were at this party and I had
another friend there and he kept her ex
kept like leaning over to my friend and
being like Satie looks so pretty I
haven't seen Satie in so long she looks
so good
and so my friend was like okay well I'll
take a picture kiss me on the cheek both
of you and then we leaned in to kiss her
on the cheek and he whispered put your
head back and so she put her head you
didn't tell me that part oh I think he
whispered it to her oh um likes to put
your head back then like we K cuz my
eyes were closed for the picture so then
we kissed and then we like kissed a
little bit and I was like he like kept
kissing yeah but that like for like a
and then I was like wait yeah what the
cuz I was like drunk so I was like o
making out and then I was like this is
not it and then I called her the next
day and I told her and then we got over
it very quickly and were you mad I was
super pissed I just felt really betrayed
I guess but then at the same time like
it made me realize how you felt when I
did that to you so it kind of felt like
karma in the most Nonny way that's
horrible but it kind of like evened out
and we made a decision that like no guy
would ever actually get in between our
relationship because it's so much more
important Audrey Madison there was a
moment uh where we tried to have a
threesome oh feel
wow no the way you guys like like this
and look it failed really bad because
the guy couldn't get hard so we were
both laying in our beds he was probably
just all scared to be honest girls award
two beautiful girls that would have been
scary too we weren't sober we so whiskey
whiskey dick it it would not it would
not go I bet he was the most UPS like he
was upset he had to be how did you both
feel about that cuz you're like this was
your first time trying to do a threesome
together yeah it was our first time and
we were just like I mean is this like is
this is this what it's should we do
something more I don't
problem bro who here would have a
threesome with their best friend I feel
like you raised your
hand right circumstance yeah yeah we
used to
like imag go ahead I'm
like we used to like
practice wait what oh like kissing each
other wait
what well cuz we're both bisexual but we
didn't really talk about that for a long
time and we would be like we should
probably practice kissing again for like
for
boys like poor boy cut to like 13 14
like rolling around on a mattress making
out like it was like really something we
had like we like got into
character really practice wait when you
guys did that did you ever catch
feelings for one another no we've talked
about this before I feel like on and off
I think it was like like crushes but not
like we would have dated each other more
just like she's so pretty and but like
at the time I don't know about her but I
didn't know that I was by so I didn't
like know that I was like enjoying it
for more than just like practice
whatever who else here has done
something sexual or hooked up with their
best
friend you want to say something go
ahead go for it we we love each other a
lot let's just say that I can't even
like like remember like what got us to
like like's try this but like we've gone
like I think when we're like drunk or
like when we're up we when we were
younger we used to go down on each other
wow I mean like for practice
or bo bo I think it was just literally
just like you're horny I'm
horny I'm not even by I'm not by she's
not by like we're not but like we have
the next prompt is I have cons
considered ending our friendship make
your split decisions in 3 2
[Music]
1 okay go ahead and turn
around oh
damn Rosalie Rebecca you both say
yes uh we lived together for a while and
it's is not a good idea yeah it's really
not unless you I don't know it's just
not I would I mean I wouldn't suggest it
it was just like a good year that we
weren't just seeing eye to eye she had
like gu stupid boyfriend that I can't
stand and I mean like I wanted to hang
out with her and then she was always
hanging out with him and then like I
just felt really alone and stuff and
there was just one thing that like would
bother me is she always left the bath
mat wet and that
was I wasn't I wasn't going to like sit
there and like end my friendship for
that but it was just like all those
things and then the bath I just don't
agree with that because that's what it's
for when you get out I mean I've heard
before like you should never live with
your best friend like it's going to be
and I was like no we're different we're
not going to be like
that but was not fine and I started like
feeling that anger from you like towards
me I didn't really like her for a little
while like everything she did will
bother me because of the fact that like
I really like we excited to move into
each other and I wanted to see her and
hang out with her and at the time I was
like you know what the hell like I let
you move in my house you know you were
going through stuff and then we don't
even hang out like so it was it was just
a bad year for this but other than that
like and then your your stupid ex was
like he was just making her feel like
stupid and insecure cuz he's and then it
just like it was just affecting it was
like all happening all at the same time
and I've definitely learn to not let a
guy like
that this have to do with a guy too no I
I I don't know what you say yes why did
you say I kill you uh no I don't think I
ever thought about it like for real for
real I think there was just moments
moment okay where I was just like this
like she's getting on my last
nerves you know what I'm saying there
were like lot of moments where we didn't
talk for like months months and months
but then we would always come back to
each other and be like hey like nothing
happened it kind of was me that stopped
talking to her cuz I just had to like
pull myself away for a minute here like
I was just like it she's doing all this
to piss me off and I just I went
back with my ex pissed her it pissed her
off because there were I'm sure
everybody
agrees so many times where she would
come to me and like be like this guy
sucks and I hate him and I'm like so
leave him like I don't understand I
think that's the one time where I was
like really talking about her at
the time cuz I was like you're my best
friend like you're supposed to be there
for every time I call or cry or like
you're not you're supposed to be no
matter what like what the like I'd do
that for you and so it was kind of like
a a slap in the face where it's like
well I get that I've been annoying with
this but like at the same time who else
am I supposed to go to we've known each
other since we were 6 years old we met
at a pool yeah at a swimming pool it was
me and my sister we were playing Marco
Polo and we were like we can't play
Marco Polo just us two and I was the
only other person in the pool it was
literally just the three of us yeah so
they were like obviously we're going to
ask this random woman uh lady sorry girl
girl I'm not a woman I'm
six and we've ever since then it's just
been nonstop hanging out a roller
coaster yeah it's been all over the
place the next prompt is my best friend
has a toxic personality trait or vice
make your split this decisions in three
1 that's hard hard give me a second
that's a toxic is a very Split Decision
what do you think go with your gut go
with your gut okay and go ahead and turn
around this is interesting right side of
the room says yay right side left side
of the room says nay okay wow you're
like you're perfect they're like no we
got some stuff stie why don't why don't
you
start Eve can be really toxic in her
romantic relationships okay so like the
eve has like
broken into an
ex okay wait now I think we all want to
know what happened not that one not that
one whatever you already said it she had
the code they had just broken up over
the phone and she drove to his place and
was banging on the door cuz she thought
that he was there and so she opened the
door and kind of broke into his house
and then that's somehow while she was in
there she found out that he was like
with someone else I think yeah damn but
she did like break into it I did out
that felt crazy to me to be honest it
did you take anything break anything
what did you do I did something insane I
should I say it yeah I going to say it
he was like constantly cheating on me
chronically so I decided okay well if
he's on a date right now cuz I just
decided in my head he was on a date um I
put on red lipstick and I kissed all
over um his house my
gosh so when he brought the girl home
there was red lipstick all over his
house did he bring somebody home he did
cuz he called me about it and called for
him oh my god wow thank you than that's
not crazy it's a little bit insane what
I thought was a little bit crazy
was like she didn't know where he was
and instead of just calling him um she
broke into his home I told is it that
the same time you almost threw food too
was that that no I did do that oh
you you I did I didn't know that what
happened you threw food at same ex like
I don't know he ordered food one day and
then while the food was coming he got
into this big fight with me I don't even
know what about there was always some
fight but once the food got there I was
at such a heightened point that I went
to bring my food home and then while I'm
sitting in my car I was like you made a
Tik Tok about it made TI about it and
then I said no I'm going back there and
I went back and I threw the takeout on
his door so it like splattered I didn't
know that she did it she was like it's
better to just leave this is me
overreacting like I could just go home
which is what I mean when I say that she
knows what to do
and then doesn't do it I'm like really
surprised that you're not up there to be
completely honest you're toxic your
relationships but like I'm toxic my
relationships too so it's kind of valid
that's why that's why I thought like we
were see I was being toxic outside
because that doesn't count like making
fake Instagrams and like checking
stories and checking followers Snapchat
scores she's been calling me every like
lately like
call some might call it toxic but you're
you're talking about making the fake
Instagrams maybe that's a toxic
trait
FBI oh give me a name I can find it
yeah and then the other thing we just
talked about your red flag yesterday oh
they want everything perfect yeah that
she just wants it makes sense like I
don't want it too hot or too cold I want
it in the middle I don't want a guy this
or this I want them in the middle cuz I
can get I can't get perfect I can you
deserve it period exactly your standards
are high yeah yeah now after my ex hell
yeah why did you say yes I think your
lack of trust and I think truly like you
like dig and dig and dig and you like
try to find problems sometimes that
don't exist because of that and I like I
agree with that and I I wish you had
more trust with the people in your life
because they truly do love you so much
and I think want the best for you and
yeah that would be my answer to that do
you agree M no
yeah I think I've just been hurt like a
lot it's just like hard for me to trust
people
sometimes she knows I trust her with
everything I think when you've been hurt
so many times it's just hard to open
up sorry you want to hug sorry I'm G to
have to
now this is such
a you guys guys are
[Music]
ad thank you for your vulnerability I
think just with family and just
relationship it's like if so many people
have broken your trust and like you feel
abandoned it's hard to like open up
still you know it's like you have a wall
up kind of thing you don't want to be
burned so yeah we met in third grade
2008 what how long ago is that I can't
do math I know I can't do math 20 15 15
years thank you we've been best friends
for 15 years yep and she's not going
anywhere she's staying yep yep the next
prompt is I keep giving my best friend
the same advice but she never listens oh
my God make your split decisions in
three 2
one okay go ahead and turn
around like
yeah Ros um I would just say for her to
slow down like she's always on the move
and like with her career which is like
okay get your money get you know move up
up but she deals with like her health um
condition was this pots you know she has
long covid like she had Co like two
years ago and she deals with it now but
I'm my girl relax please like she
stresses me out she doesn't eat and I
have to get on her I'm like dude protein
shake do something you know and I just
want her just to take a minute breather
it's okay like I get it that you want to
do better but at the same time please
take care of your health and she just
stresses me out to be honest so like she
literally I know I guess it's just
dresses me out it's so hard for me oh
God I know I'm sorry that's okay it's
just like really hard for me to watch
people like live life and like I just
feel like Left Behind
sometimes um I got really sick last year
from covid and it um just made me have a
lot of like Health complications so like
I don't know I I I shouldn't be doing
some of the stuff that I'm I should be
like I I'm doing I just push myself so
hard because I if I stay in my room and
I think about it too long I'm just going
to get depressed so I'm like try to push
myself as much as I can cuz it's just
it's hard watching life go by like
without you cuz no one's going to life's
not going to slow down everybody else is
living their life I that's why I try to
like keep up with everybody else but I
know that you just care about me and
like I know you really really care about
me when it comes to like the health
stuff so I appreciate and I'm trying to
eat more I know that and your mental
health you know I want you to just the
journal I know that's a big thing like
please Journal please get these thoughts
out of your head and put them on the
paper I'm telling you'll help but you
know that's because it works for me so
not everything works for others but I
just want her to give it a
try stie what's your advice leave when
you're not happy is the first one um I
understand why you do the things that
you do sometimes um but I think you
would get out of those situations and be
happier faster if you
didn't act on those impulses and also um
like take time apart when you're first
dating someone don't spend every day
together when you met last week I need I
need that advice no you mean you
definitely it's a lesson learned we've
learned that
yeah yeah the next prompt is there's a
part of our friendship that still needs
healing make your split decisions in
three 2
[Music]
one okay go ahead and turn
around
oh let's start with you um I guess just
talking
about those things that happened with
each other's exes I could see that we
both got pretty I I just know you and I
know that when we both get in those
moods it's easy to feel how you're
feeling and it seems like maybe we need
to talk about it more I want to make
sure that you know every everything that
happened yeah and I don't ever want
there to be something that comes up
later I think honestly I don't know I
don't think that I still am like hurt by
that situation I don't feel like I care
about what happened in high school okay
fair I mean with you two I've known
about it long enough that I feel like
for me like I don't know honestly when
it comes to him I'm like anything anyone
tells me I'm not shocked at this point
okay so Eve but you think that she
hasn't quite healed yet based on what
her ex did I don't know if it's not
quite healed but it's the fact that I
don't think I told you everything and I
feel like I need to so there something
you need to tell her not right I mean
well yeah I guess I can say it here but
yeah I mean it did happen multiple times
it wasn't just one time yeah okay okay
okay but like I don't
he's like yeah everything happened
multiple times with him you know like
yeah I'm not on the edge of my isn't
news to you no this isn't news to me he
was a repeat offender on many things I'm
not shocked that that happened more than
once I'm also not shocked that she did
it more than once not because I don't
trust you because he's incredibly
manipulative okay people tell me all the
time like when I go home they're like ah
this happened I'm like yeah of course it
did so stie you didn't know that Eve
hooked up with your ex multiple times
not really I suspected but I I suspected
I suspected that it happened more than
once they were good friends they were
around each other when I wasn't around a
lot but I didn't like no one had told me
yeah the next prompt is if my best
friend were my daughter I'd be proud of
her make your split decisions in 3 2
I love hear one step for
everybody
whoever one step I heard only one step
for
everybody I'm just really proud of you
forry we've just like we've both like
been in like super dark places before
and that's where we like connected but
it wasn't just you know a trauma B
whatever we we got got each other each
other out of those places and then
seeing you now the way that you're going
to the gym you're working on your mental
health like I'm so proud of you because
like the person that you were last year
is not even compar comparable to how you
are now and I'm just like really proud
of you for just your confidence has gone
up you know that you're beautiful and I
I'm just proud of you I just love her
like who wouldn't have her as a daughter
she is basically M you I take care of
her I'm always watching out for her
weever we go out like I'm the one that's
like okay you guys move out the way you
know she's walking yeah I'm very
protective over here cuz I love her and
then yeah like we had to have a trama
Bond but we just always just been there
for each other like yeah we had that one
year that we're all just not really okay
but like I love her to death like she's
here forever it's like it's like there's
no other person I'd get into a fight for
except her like like and i' i' and this
girl doesn't fight dude I don't fight
for to save my life but I choked a dude
out for her like that's oh my God chok a
dude out dude this guy was breaking her
heart and she came up to me crying and
sobbing and like I don't not a lot of
people see her that side of her of like
just like that vulnerable side so like I
immediately was like triggered and I was
drunk too so I was like context we were
at a party and I had hooked up with him
like the day before and he told me that
he broke up with his girlfriend and when
I went to the party him and his
girlfriend were there together oh my God
and so I wasn't crying over him I was
crying for the girl I felt so bad he was
like oh I need to go talk to her like I
need to go talk to her I was like no the
you're not like I grabbed him and I put
him against the wall I was like you're
not fing her she doesn't want to see you
and you're going to leave the alone and
so like just that's the only that's the
only she's the only person I will ever
get like that for and I have a sister
but like that's that's family like the
next prompt is there's something I
haven't told my best friend that I want
to get off my chest make your split
decisions in three two
one
okay and go ahead and turn
around I want to
cry okay Caitlyn you're the only one who
says yes I just you are the strongest
person I've ever met like Hannah's had
so much happened this year and like
yesterday
too like you're here right now so I
don't know how you're standing it like
being okay like her dog died yesterday
like we out so sorry like and she's had
him forever and it's like you were like
smiling still like laughing like I don't
know how you do it like I wish I had
that because like I'm not like that I
would literally sit in my bed all day
like I can't do that like you are
literally the strongest person I've ever
met in my life I feel like all these
girls can say the same thing about their
best friend too like you are the
strongest person and I wish I had that
like in my future daughter too like the
question before like I want that in my
daughter so yeah you're my best friend
you're like my
family B we about to get drunk
tonight I
know um I just wish that like more
people not just me told you like how
great you
are
like how
proud
because I feel like you with your family
you don't hear it as much as you should
and I wish that you
did cuz I think that you're great and I
think you need to hear it
more
iug
yeah that was so nice I didn't think we'
cry today guys I know I the whole
time I don't really do stuff like this I
was like I was really anxious before I'm
not going to lie but I'm actually glad
because this is something that we're
going to be able to see later on in life
and just like you know laugh about it
and love think that like when we have
kids we could watch it on our 10 year
anniversary with a little cake oh yeah
we're going to do like a little 10 year
anniversary with our cake oh I love
you get
drunk I don't think there's anything you
can tell me that will make me feel badly
towards you I just just value what you
say um so much so that I really really
took that to heart and meant the world
to me so thank you for saying that love
you I love you and that concludes this
episode of split decision I just want to
say ladies thank you so much for coming
here today being vulnerable sharing your
truth it really was beautiful courageous
and I thank you from the bottom of my
heart and I think everyone here thanks
you
too I in I get in
I'm
so I
[Music]
you